- I can walk into the
White House right now.
I can go sleep, I can go
sleep in the President's
sheets if I'm invisible,
and do it every day when
he's out playing basketball.
- Yeah, you're just committing crime.
- All the secrets of the world are yours,
information, free flowing guys.
That's my knowledge of getting,
why, you know what I'm saying?
- Did you just have a mental breakdown?
- Yeah, I did.
- Look, we all want super powers,
and obviously the best two are flight,
or invisibility.
Imagine the miracle of flight,
soaring through the clouds,
the wind through your hair.
Or, you could be some creepy little
invisible perv, sneaking
into a locker room.
I might be kind of biased on this one,
but in the interests of the pervs,
we'll try and keep it a fair fight.
Flight versus invisibility,
it's Debatable.
- Flying is for children.
- I'm for flight.
- I'm very much pro-invisibility.
- Today I'm arguing for flight.
- I'm pro-flight 'cause, duh.
- Pro-invisibility.
- Team flight.
- [Man Behind Chair] I'm for invisibility,
ah, you thought I was
invisible for a second.
- Flying has been man's
dream since the beginning
- What about woman's dream?
Invisibility?
- Woman's dream doesn't matter.
- Garrett, I like you,
and if we're just talking,
we're gonna go to coffee,
you just fly away, I'm
never talking to you
again 'cause you're a freak.
- Travel, cheap, easy.
- Tons of holes in that argument, but.
- Oh my God, no traffic jams, good night!
You could go anywhere so fast.
- You ever been to New York City, Zack?
- I have.
- How long did it take for you to get to
New York City?
- Six hours.
- Six hours, and that's just in the plane.
- Gotta check with the TSA.
- No, that is not part of it.
- I'm sure there's,
- You're not carrying cargo.
- You know how much tickets cost for
the Super Bowl?
Imagine being able to just hover right
above the field?
- That'd be pretty cool,
imagine getting sniped by the US military
when you're doing that.
- You're interrupting the show.
- That's not true.
- That's my other problem
with flying around,
little flashy, don't you think?
Oh, look at me, awh.
- Leaving your stomach
exposed to every one
down below that could
just shoot you in the
cock, or the boobs, in your case.
- What kind of an argument is this?
- Imagine me just putting
on a space helmet,
or a scuba tank, I'm
just gonna fly to space.
I'm gonna see what space is like.
- It's not that great,
I've seen the Martian.
- I could be studied at some point.
- I don't want to be a test experiment.
You don't wanna be,
- I'm an organ donor.
- There's a fun prank that you could do by
flying too, you just
make a really, really big
bird costume, and then
you're the Loch Ness
monster of the sky.
- Can you dress like a
dragon and make people
think you're a dragon in the sky?
No you cannot, because you're invisible.
- That's the prank?
- The prank is on you,
you're donning a Party City costume
and flying over the,
- Oh it would not be a Party City costume.
I would get a majority
of it from Joann Fabrics.
- If a bird poops, falls out,
are you gonna be pooping
on people Garrett?
- No, I'm not gonna be pooping on people!
When you're on top of a building,
and you see people like walking by,
are you just like,
you know what, I think I wanna poop on
them like a bird?
- If there was a getaway plan, maybe.
- Think of the movies
you could sneak into,
you can sneak into another movie.
- The movies?
- You want to be flying
above the Super Bowl?
How about being on the field,
on the action.
- You're gonna get knocked over.
- You don't gotta go sit
up in the nose bleeds
either, you can get right on the stage.
- I could be backstage with Beyonce.
I could be Beyonce's
friend and she wouldn't
even know, is this creepy?
Yes.
- How about being in the locker room,
hearing what the coach is
telling Payton Manning.
- This is perfect, 'cause you're already
talking about sneaking into locker rooms.
Bingo!
- You little creep, you
just wanna see boobs.
- You got me, I want to see naked people.
- Unfortunately for you, I'm not a perv,
so I wouldn't use it for that.
- It's not unfortunate for me.
- I'm living in a world where people use
invisibility for good.
I'm not living in this, Clay Aiken,
fly on the wall, shit.
- I would rather do cool things,
like walk into a bank, just feel money.
Not even take it, just feel money.
Have you ever done that?
- You just wanna be a ghost?
- No, 'cause I wanna be alive,
and have a soul still,
and a family one day.
- You can break into banks and take money,
and give it to the poor
and no one's gonna know.
- Just straight up committing crimes.
- No it's not, I'm trying to help.
- Trespassing.
- That Peter Pan was committing crimes by
trespassing on those rich people's places.
- Peter Pan, who the fuck?
- Steal from the rich, give to the needy.
- All money is digital now anyways,
how is that, do you also
have computer hacking skills?
- I do when I stand behind.
I'm like, oh, his passwords "password",
really Mr. President?
- I could be at the office,
and if I want to hear
what my boss is saying,
or something like that.
I mean, of course, I'd
have to strip down naked,
but I mean, there's some things you have
to do before anything,
you have to put batteries in a remote, so.
- Right.
- All your points are,
I want to commit crimes.
- But no guys, don't help
out people by stealing
from these top secret things,
watch me fly!
- I mean, invisible people
still leave footprints.
- I'll wear shoes that
look like bear tracks.
- Could you imagine if
you saw just invisible
bear tracks?
- Could you imagine a
bear that's invisible?
That's literally now the,
- That's the scariest thing in the world.
- It's an ultimate killing machine.
Now we're getting off track.
Fuck bears.
- Any super power to have, no matter what,
we're gonna be rich, right?
- Oh, we're making money.
- We're gonna be making bank.
- Invisibility's obviously the superior
super power here, it's more practical.
- Invisibility and flight together,
would be the ultimate super power.
And I don't know why
that wasn't an option.
- Flying is beautiful, flying is elegant,
flying is right.
- It's clear that
invisibility is the way to go.
- Just fly, man, because
we've always wanted to.
- What else, I mean, you
tell us in the comments,
what do you like?
- [Voiceover] Invisibility you're like,
get that boy!
They're like, whoa!
I'm going in between their legs,
I'm like, over here, tapping
them on the shoulder.
That's what invisibility does.
Flying is just like,
"Hey I'm gonna go be by
myself and fly around."
You'd be a great pizza delivery boy.